you have like a diagonal line I'm so
glad you asked so now let's just picture
for a second okay I want you to imagine
right in fact let's not imagine you've
got this picture you see yeah okay now I
am started drawing this based on my
green set of coordinate axis yes but if
those axes were not there right Kevin
that guy think back to when I phrase the
question to you okay I've got a point
I've gone why I want all of the the pot
that's traced out by that moving point
equidistant right now all I want you to
do is just just turn your head like to
see not looking it straight now if you
turn your head at any which way you're
still getting the same locus right it
doesn't matter which orientation you're
looking at it right so for example now
putting your head back to normal if I
said alright here's some other point and
he is some other line right some other
fence that I want should be the same
distance wrong okay you still get the
same pattern the same path being traced
out it's just that if you start to piece
together the points your parabola goes
off in a different direction
okay it could go off that way it could
go horizontally okay it can go any which
way you like depending on what kind of a
line you have over there okay so being
that this point right it's kind of like
where did the winner these points kind
of go around right they kind of focal
focusing around this point this is
called the focal point right that's its
name or more simply to the focus okay so
the focal point or the focus this point
defines where it's floating around
okay this line down here because what it
sets for you is the direction that the
parabola ends up facing the direction
that the parabola is facing we call that
and this is why I call it
we call it the directrix this line down
here which I gave you is y equals
negative three or I could give you some
wheat a bleak thing or a vertical thing
which would be like x equals some
constant that thing is what sets the
direction of this guy and so therefore
it's called the directrix right it's
facing away from the directrix as it
were okay
yes if I want if I want the focus would
be the focal point to be here [ __ ] is
right and I want the predatory facing
down right it's still gonna be going
around the focus but I want the
directrix to be directing it that way
right so you see how I thought maybe
this directrix is basically making her
that way
this directrix is making it that way
this directrix speaking that way right
if I want this thing to face down I just
put the directrix above right and the
parabola the results will face away from
the direct correct because here's what
would happen if I had the line somewhere
right yeah would intercept right and
then if you've got say the focus here
this doesn't work you know for example
if I pick an arbitrary point of kreplach
like say whatever the point P is zero
distance from the line but it is some
distance from the focus so it no longer
obeys this geometric property that we
started with the distance is not the
same